you're stung by a jellyfish what's your
first course of action maybe home
remedies pop into your mind peeing on
the sting site applying ice or using
baking soda if tentacles are sticking to
your skin you probably feel like you
want to scrape them off but none of
these treatments work and some will make
things worse and if you're stung by a
box jellyfish that could make the
difference between life and death
we're in an area where there's very
little tolerance for mistakes and things
that make things worse our real tragedy
in our mind that's angel yanagihara a
researcher at the University of Hawaii
at Manoa who has been studying jellyfish
venom for two decades box jellyfish
members of the Cuba's OA class live in
tropical and temperate waters around the
world they're common in the Pacific near
the coast of the Philippines Indonesia
Thailand Malaysia and Australia they
inject venom into your skin by firing
microscopic hypodermic needles at speeds
of more than 60 kilometres an hour the
venom is a chemical cocktail that at
high doses can cause cardiac arrest in
less than five minutes
Yanagi hada has developed products to
counter the sting a spray containing
vinegar and urea and a cream containing
copper gluconate the spray so he stops
the cells from firing the tentacle from
firing all this venom it doesn't stop
the venom that's already in the body the
cream on the other hand does that
yanagihara stresses that some home
remedies also work simple vinegar can
stop unfired venom cells as well and he
can block venom already injected not
everybody agrees however one scientist
says vinegar can actually make things
worse
all jellyfish venom scientists agree
that more research is needed on how the
venom works and what can be done to stop
it in just the months of June and July
itself there were at least three kids I
guess you can call them who died from
box jellyfish in the Phillip
it might just seem like a minor part of
the first-aid compendium and what does
it matter if you say put ice on it or
put heat on it or put either on it if
one takes a global perspective then it's
pretty clear pretty rapidly why that
matters
another question needs more research as
well how many people get stung by
jellyfish and how many died there are no
official statistics and yanagihara
thinks the problem is more serious than
people realize when I went to these
rural health offices and I would ask the
group how many people had been stung by
box jellyfish a good third and a lot of
these places would raise their hands
unfortunately in the Philippines most of
these deaths aren't aren't recorded
aren't ever reported forward they're
considered environmental accidents and
so they're basically lost to us to get a
better handle on the problem Yanagi
hadas team is surveying health workers
and coastal communities in the
philippines they're also educating
people about the risk of jellyfish
stings and conducting research on the
jellyfish population so we see our role
there in a three-part way one is the
public health piece which is getting the
data one is the public education piece
which is about prevention and
understanding and then the third piece
is just the field ecology better
understanding jellyfish ecology might
help prevent injury because people could
be warned about when to avoid the water
the solution could be as simple as just
making people realize that this is this
can kill is when they come don't really
go into the sea at this at this point a
year by showing that jellyfish are a
serious public health problem
Yanagi hada hopes that research funders
will pay more attention if jellyfish
stings are underreported basically they
don't meet even the most minor threshold
for any asset allocation professional
scientists need to be really even more
engaged in the public sphere and in
cases in which
there's real emotional pain and
suffering if scientists stay in the
ivory tower the general populace doesn't
feel connected with scientists
[Music]